Hi, this is Hongju leading the
computational immersion alignment
research lab in the active inverse
institute. We develop the AI alignment
solution inspired by computational
phnology and adult development theory.
The core question guiding this research
is can artificial systems mature. So
traditional area alignment often relies
on externally imposed rules and
constraints and these can work in narrow
settings. Um but in complex changing
environments rigid constraints can lead
to brittleness and unpredictable
behavior. So here a developmental
approach asks something different.
Instead of injecting alignment from the
top down, can coherence emerge from the
systems own experimental structure?
Inspired by developmental psychology and
contemplative models of maturation, we
explore whether artificial systems can
gradually integrate perception, value,
and decision-m into more stable internal
organization.
So we can think of this as a paradigm
shift. So where the traditional paradigm
is largely top down in terms of defining
the predefined goals and fixed value
systems and externally define
constraints in constraints um alignment
from development is rather bottom up in
in a sense that it emphasizes
experimental learning and experiential
learning I mean adaptive value formation
and coherence that evolves in response
to environmental complexity. So here the
difference is heavily important in terms
of that one approach tries to control
behavior and the other tries to
cultivate structural maturity.
To make this concrete we are developing
perspective based agent architectures.
So here the idea is that agents capable
of development should organize
experience from a particular standpoint
which is called a minimal subjective
perspective
and um through environmental interaction
the system accumulates experience via
active exploration.
So internally it integrates these
experiences into coherent structures but
gradually forming its own evaluative
criteria uh rather than relying on fixed
exter external signals
over time. This allows for gradual
maturation in terms of more stable and
robust behavioral patterns that arise
from internal organization.
You hear the longer road map unfolds
across three phases. So phase one
focuses on perspective formation which
is currently in progress and from this
phase we validate the minimal
developmental structures in controlled
environments.
Phase two moves into more complex and
multi- aent settings where systems must
must adapt and negotiate the value
conflicts and learn socially. Phase
three exam is longer term alignment
asking whether coherent value systems
can emerge and remain stable in changing
environments.
[snorts]
This work is already in motion. So the
theoretical and empirical foundation has
been established including a preprint on
modeling subjective perspective and a
functional simulation prototype has been
implemented
uh in terms of de demonstrating the
proof of concept and phase one
experiments are currently underway
focusing on validating perspective
information and coherence dynamics under
uncertainty.
So this is an active research program at
a critical transition point.
The broader impact of this work is a new
paradigm for AI safety where instead of
enforcing alignment externally, we
explore how more robust and attunable
systems might arise through intrinsic
growth. So where such systems may be
more adaptive and resilient responding
um appropriately to new situations
because their coherence is internally
structured. So ultimately this will open
the possibility of co-evolution in terms
of AI systems that develop alongside
human society rather than being
constrained by it.
A research research [clears throat] at
the edge of new paradigms um often
depends on small but critical structural
bridges
and um this project is currently at a
transition point where continued support
ensures that it does not pause here. So
thank you for your support.